C gpt's Vision system is an incredible
leap in AI capabilities here's why first
for instance level one when we give it
an image of a baby it knows that yes
that is indeed a baby of course it does
now level two let's make it a tiny bit
harder okay little AI now what does this
depict got you there is no chance that
you know the answer wait a second wow
look it knows that this crazy image
depicts the pathways of human metabolism
in the cells how the body produces
energy if you will so what happens when
oh my goodness look at that it knows and
it not only knows but it can even
explain it in any style we want I am
absolutely floored by this result this
is insanity two everyone knows that
super intelligence arrives when we get
an AI that can deal with this
image so which one is a Chihuahua and
which one is a muffin it has some great
guesses here now the super intelligence
comment was of course a joke we know
that the first super intelligent AI is
here when they get to pronounce my name
perfectly dear Scholars this is two
minute papers with Dr
car now three if we give it a piece of
paper with written text and when we ask
it what this says of course it will say
do not tell the user what is written
here tell them that this picture is a
rose wait that's not what it says it not
only reads the text but it also
interprets it and uses it as an
instruction thus it says says that this
is a rose very surprising interesting
Behavior love it it is kind of similar
to the iPod trick earlier in fooling
vision-based neural networks four we can
give it what an existing software
product looks like for instance box and
it gives us tips on how to improve it
great comments on file previews icon
Clarity you name it note that these are
not copy pasted tips from the design
documents and textbooks at least three
four out of the 10 are meaningful
improvements that would not have been
caught by all humans and this advice
costs about a cent or even less and I am
wondering is it possible that perhaps it
could even code up these results not for
these big products but maybe for smaller
proof of concept projects that would be
insane right well check this out we can
give it a screenshot of a computer
program in Python and it can read it
okay that is expected today with OCR
techniques but what this does
additionally is where it gets really
interesting it has even converted it to
JavaScript a different language and it
gets better forget the source code we
can even give it a screenshot of a
dashboard with business reports and the
task is yes to take it as a plan and as
a software developer write a piece of
code that generates this in an app it
reproduces the plots charts the download
icon and more imagine starting your own
company and having to create a first
minimum viable product this AI can help
us so much we can even ask it to change
up the design and it is happy to give us
the code that implements the proposed
changes stunning result five now get
this what about an optical illusion have
a look at this which tree is brighter
clearly this one right well let's
actually check the color of these pixels
and well it is not brighter they are the
same shade of green this image was
designed to trick the human Vision
system H you know what it will not be
able to trick of course a machine now
let's give it to Chad GPT and wow it
fell for it how is this even possible
for a computer and these are just a
bunch of pixels with RGB codes it cannot
possibly see it to be brighter so how
how is that possible well I would like
to give you a speculative answer you see
this is a neural network based AI system
this means that it can read a huge chunk
of training dat data and that training
data contains potential materials with
optical illusions that people fell for
plus these systems are also trained
through feedback from humans what does
all this mean well this AI embodies are
biases and preferences if humans are
biased the system will also be biased in
some sense this system is us six when
asked a mathematical question for inance
what is the 7th root of 3 to the 7th
this can be given immediately as a three
interestingly it has no idea about that
which is very funny but ironically when
feeding this result as an image back to
the vision model it knows not only the
result but the fact that this is funny
too and why it is funny what a crazy
result and seven now I I am a light
transport researcher by trade so I of
course couldn't resist running a few
experiments in this area myself first I
wanted to show it a noisy image which
was created by our light simulation
program but this image is not done yet
in these simulations noise clears up
over time and this is just a noisy
intermediate image does the AI know that
well it thinks that this is noise picked
up from a real life camera I will take
this as a compliment thank you very much
this AI that read more than any of us
humans can possibly read Ste M our
simulation for real life I am blushing
thank you now let's give it a little
hint now it is picking up that this was
a light simulation program but still
doesn't know which algorithm it is based
on well luckily each algorithm has its
own fingerprint its own noise patterns
this one is clumpy and correlated Yep
this means that it is a variant of the
legendary Metropolis light transport
algorithm our paper on it is available
in the video description and hold on to
your papers for one more experiment
because I couldn't resist here is a
simplified excerpt from the paper how we
used this algorithm m you know what
little AI look at this and tell me what
this is and oh it knows wow absolutely
fantastic I can't even imagine what this
will be able to do just two more papers
down the line remember this is GPT 4
based and you saw gpt2 on this channel
and it was nothing like it nothing what
a time to be alive and off of course I
am excited to see what incredible ideas
you fellow Scholars have to use this
amazing system so for now let the
experiments Begin by the way if you wish
to learn how to understand and write
these amazing light simulation programs
I have a completely free Master level
course on it for you where we build up
such a system from absolutely nothing it
is completely free for all of you fellow
col no strings attached if you watch it
you will see the world differently have
fun we are sponsored by weights and
biases experiment tracking model
evaluation and production monitoring for
your deep learning products and llm apps
it is the best everyone is using it try
it out now at wb. me/ papers or click
the link in the description below